donc entre agression a eu lieu hier soir
c'est ça est-ce que vous avez vu les
agresseurs
ça va peut-être nous aider on va faire
un portrait robot essayé dans la base de
données paf au la trappe d'accord jour
logicielle et je vous pose quelques
questions
on est parti alors est ce que votre
agresseur est un homme bah oui on sait
des questions de base 1 donc
donc oui oui est ce que votre agresseur
aurait plus de 30 ans oui est ce que
votre agresseur serait-il de votre
famille ma famille parce que je sors et
qui sait ouais bah vous me dites non à
l'or non non non non non ce n'est pas
non est-ce que votre agresseur aurait
déjà enregistré un disque un discours
est vrai que je le sache
c'est quoi ces questions dans la
grisaille gens sérieux si on se calme
ensuite le protocole on répond à vos
questions vous savez pas où dit non
alors est ce que votre agresseur serait
t'il décédé je veux marquer non non
est ce que votre agresseur aurait-il d
origine asiatique
oui ah oui oui attendez est ce que votre
agresseur
serait-il un humoriste mais oui oui oui
est ce que votre agresseur aurait-il une
chronique teulet 6 1 mais oui la
chronique télé j'ai trouvé c'est jean
luc lemoine
si je reconnais son petit fils de [ __ ]
vous l'avez trouvé en quelques clics
sommes dues seulement et je sais pas de
koumac usa d'une client ne parlera pas
et je ne sais pas qui est ce délateur
qui est akinator mais au vu de son
accoutrement un petit gilet un turban
sur la tête je ne pense pas qu'il ait
ses papiers nationalité française merci
à tous
celle du client bon
k